[Musique]
en ce mois de septembre 2018 un monstre
est en train de naître au coeur de
l'océan atlantique
l'ouragan vient d'être baptisé florence
et les autorités américaines veulent
tout savoir sur lui
les experts des services de la météo le
traverse dans un avion spécialement
équipées
et ils sont formels
sa puissance est phénoménal il est
immédiatement classé en catégorie 4 sur
l'échelle saffir simpson qui en compte
cinq
voici l'oeil du cyclone son diamètre
représente la distance entre lille et
marseille soit 1000 km
s'il ne faiblit pas la proche des terres
les rafales de vents dépassant les 200
km/heure et les millions de mètres cubes
d'eau qu'ils transportent promettent des
pluies diluviennes
[Musique]
une petite ville de caroline du nord est
directement menacée
dans 72 heures elle sera touchée
florence fait craindre le pire
[Musique]
en temps ordinaire wilmington à la
réputation d'une paisible cité balnéaire
qui offrent le décor de son bord de mer
à de nombreuses séries télé américaines
une ville habituée à subir des tempêtes
tropicales
mais cette fois si les habitants vont
devoir faire face à un phénomène d'une
toute autre ampleur les autorités
viennent de décréter l'état d'urgence
fait exceptionnel le gouverneur rick
hooper lance un avertissement solennel
j'ai un message urgent pour tous les
habitants de la caroline du nord
florence va impacter chacun d'entre nous
j'ordonne l'évacuation de toutes les
zones du littoral
et j'invite les habitants de la caroline
à obéir aux ordres d'évacuation des
autorités locales
[Musique]
à 24 heures de son arrivée les bulletins
météo se succèdent
alarmiste
une énorme tempête qui se prépare un
ouragan dévastateur
regardez à quel point l'eau va monter
les vents vont tout emporté les voitures
flotteront à ce stade l'eau arrivera au
dessus de ma tête
voici selon les spécialistes ce qui
attend les habitants dans quelques
heures
c'est un scénario qui vous placera en
danger de mort l'eau atteindra le
premier étage de vos maisons puis le
second
les poissons floch trop autour de vue
c'est extrêmement dangereux donc si vous
vous trouvez là en ce moment s'il vous
plaît partez obéissez aux ordres
d'évacuation
écoutez les autorités et les conseils
qu'ils nous donnent
[Musique]
à wilmington c'est une ville de plus de
100000 habitants qui organise son
évacuation
la plupart se précipitent dont les
derniers supermarchés ouverts pour faire
des provisions de produits de première
nécessité
[Musique]
des dizaines d'écoles ferme les stations
d'essence sont prises d'assaut et
bientôt à sec
[Musique]
tout le long de la côte un million de
personnes prennent la route et l'est où
derrière elle
florence sera là dans douze heures il
faut faire vite
le centre national des ouragans a mis en
garde contre une montée des eaux
potentiellement mortelle les habitations
du front de mer sont les plus exposés
l'ouragan porte en lui une réserve de 40
milliards de litres d'eau un mètre de
pluie est attendue par endroits
c'est la pire des tempêtes qui arrive on
essaie de protéger les vitrines des
objets projetée par le vent
beaucoup de gens ne vont pas rentrer les
panneaux où les affaires et tout ça va
finir par s'envoler
petit à petit la ville se vide
wilmington prend des allures de cité
fantôme
nous avons décidé de vivre ce moment aux
côtés de ceux qui ont choisi de rester
malgré les avertissements malgré les
mises en garde
[Musique]
dans ce quartier sur les hauteurs un
français se préparent à affronter son
premier ouragan
[Musique]
davines un ingénieur lorrain vie dans
cette maison avec sa femme américaine
maggie et leurs deux enfants de deux et
quatre ans
habitué aux tempêtes leurs voisins
n'évacue pas
alors lui et sa femme décide de rester
en prenant quelques précautions
donc on a vidé les piquets
on peut prêche pas 50 cm dans au sol
elle n'a pas cédé
à la passer des câbles
ne sera pas même si ça bouge
regardez moi je suis comme un petit
singe se rendent pas compte
face au silence des enfants
de vide s'est préparé comme pour une
semaine de camping
il a rempli les plaqueurs de provisions
classé notre petite réserve pour petites
semaines je pense boiteux cancer n'est
pas trop on n'est pas trop boîtes de
conserve j'en sais pas
les enfants profitent de leur dernier
repas avec de bons légumes frais
david et meggie sont sereins l'état de
caroline du nord distille on a vu
d'autres
fréquents
[Musique]
al'approche de la terrible florence le
pays entier a les yeux rivés sur la
caroline du nord
il n'y a pas de temps à perdre deux
millions de personnes ont reçu l'ordre
d'évacuer
c'est pas obligatoire
on attend
on vit pas sur la plage
je pense qu'on est bon là c'est bizarre
à dire ses à-côtés excitation
même si les voilà faut être sérieux faut
se préparer mais ce côté humain ce
qu'est ce que ce qu'est ce que ça va
donner parce que c'est nouveau pour moi
jamais jamais vécu ça la cua
de l'autre côté de la ville un autre
français alban le boulanger épicier de
wilmington
lui a déjà vécu des ouragans c'est un
habitué de ces événements et il a acquis
des réflexes
avec sa femme joséphine il a investi
toutes ses économies dans ce commerce
craignant les dégâts ils ont mis leurs
marchandises à l'abri dans ses frigos
tous les fromages de chèvre qu'on a ici
les les saucisses de foie gras
les pattes et je suis sûr que les
chambres froides sont bien au froid vu
qu'on va avoir des coupures
d'électricité certainement jaser a
ralenti au maximum plus froid j'espère
qu'au cas où sa coupe sar au froid assez
longtemps avant que l'électricité
revienne c'est un peu bizarre comme
sentiment c'est tellement calme avant tu
as du mal à imaginer que
va se passer ce qu'ils disent qu'il va
se passer et puis d'un autre côté tu
vois partir ou fait avoir des millions
de personnes sur la route pour revenir
ça risque de prendre deux à trois
semaines entre toutes les personnes qui
sont sur la route tout les inondations
qui va avoir
dans le country side avec toutes les
rivières et tous les bras de mer qui a
c'est encore pire ça peut une année avec
le dernier ouragan qui l'a eu en france
à deux à trois semaines pour les gens
vont revenir c'est joli comme nom
florence dommage
bah on voit que ça commence à souffler
ça commence à venir petit à petit on va
voir comme un temps ça dure tous ces
arbres
l'ouragan a maintenant atteint la
caroline du nord
le vent se lève sur wilmington
je peux vous dire que les ventes
à la tombée de la nuit albon séquelles
feutrée chez lui florence est annoncée
dans la nuit dans à peine 5 heures
une heure du matin florence est
maintenant juste au dessus de leur tête
l'ouragan vient d'être rétrogradée en
niveau 1
je vois les arbres la ouate a vu les
éclaire
les lignes électriques scène sous les
assauts du vent
toute la ville est désormais privés de
courant
[Musique]
au moins on a de l'eau
sur l'ouragan va mettre du temps à
partir
impossible de trouver le sommeil cette
nuit
progressant très lentement l'ouragan
s'acharne sur wilmington
[Applaudissements]
si jamais le vent s'engouffre dans
l'appartement
que les fenêtres explosées que tout vol
ici alors il faut s'abriter dans un
endroit sans fenêtre surtout sans
fenêtre et si nécessaire tu as partant
matelas et si quelque chose de temps
dessus ou que le plafond s'effondre ces
réformes je vais protéger par le matelas
comme alban et joséphine les habitants
sont restés cloîtrés chez eux toutes les
nuits
au petit matin la force des vents est
toujours aussi impressionnante y souffle
sans discontinuer toute la journée
le long de la côte les éléments se
déchaînent
les vidéos prises par les rares
personnes qui osent mettre leur nez
dehors montre la violence si la
puissance des rafales
les précipitations hors norme
et le niveau de la mer qui monte en un
temps record
ces quelques heures qui suivent le
passage de florence
c'est le moment attendu par blake et
patrick deux chasseurs de tempête
là ça devait être vraiment une énorme
rafales de vent parce qu'elle a arraché
ce toit elle a même coupé cet arbre au
travers de la route
il traque les dégâts les plus
impressionnants en espérant vendre leur
image aux chaînes de télévision
américaines
c'est qu'on essaie vraiment de faire
c'est de montrer à quel point cette
tempête est dangereuse pour qu'on puisse
éduquer les gens sur la nécessité de
fuir
et c'est vraiment ça qui est important
on a besoin que les gens comprennent ce
que ça veut dire quand les éléments se
déchaînent pour qu'ils se rendent compte
derrière leur télévision qu'il ne faut
pas rester sous un ouragan
attention il y à des câbles électriques
qui pendent damas il pourrait tomber on
ne sait jamais s'il ya du courant
tiens je vais essayé de filmer ça
toujours sur les traces de la tempête
blake et patrick suis florence sur cette
application spéciale qui les informe en
direct de ces évolutions
pour l'instant l'ouragan n'a rien perdu
de sa puissance bien au contraire
là les vents ils soufflent à 112 km
heure
ah oui quand-même regarde ces bâtiments
ils ont vraiment subi de gros dégâts
l'océan envahi les rues partout sur la
côte
alors que les pluies font déborder les
rivières
à wilmington on relève déjà deux morts
une mère et son bébé écrasé par cet
arbre pendant leur sommeil
une huître frayeur vécue aussi par david
l'ingénieur lorrain il filme lui même
les inondations avec son téléphone et il
est inquiet
tornade hier rien arranger du tout
un peu de marge
nous retrouvons son quartier dévasté un
arbre est tombé pile devant sa maison
au deuxième jour de l'ouragan
le père de famille visiblement secoué
on sentait vraiment la maison qui m'a
quittée bouger quoi
super noir des bruits un peu partout un
peu étrange le vent qui paraît qui fait
des bruits à tout moment se demande
si c'est pas le toit qui va partir
d'entretiens de question donc c'est dur
de juste endormi dire ok demain matin ça
va aller quoi ça n'a pas beaucoup dormi
malgré les amarres les jeux des enfants
se sont envolés
david a conscience d'avoir joué avec sa
vie et celle de sa famille
la prochaine fois qu'ils annoncent sa
catégorie 4 je pense qu'on va quitter la
maison parce que
je me disais non ça va aller ça arrivait
en catégorie 2 et c'était
c'était impressionnant quoi
regretté de rester non j'suis pas non
non j'ai pas regretter du tout mais la
prochaine fois qu'ils annoncent sa
catégorie 4 que même trois jeux
réfléchir à deux fois ce que je me dis
qu'on a eu de la chance qu'ils
arrivaient en 2éme m en 1 il a fini en
catégorie t1 avec beaucoup de vent
en deux jours 60 centimètres de pluie se
sont abattus sur wilmington
la cité se réveille les pieds dans l'eau
les routes sont inondées la ville coupée
du reste du pays
les gardes-côtes évacuent les habitants
les plus isolés en hélicoptère avec
leurs animaux
en tout florence a endommagé quatre
mille habitations
un million de foyers sont privés
d'électricité
sur les routes coupées par les arbres
alban et joséphine n'ont qu'une
obsession rejoindre au plus vite leur
boulangerie pour voir si leurs stocks de
marchandises zinat a tenu monde
mon dieu sérieux tu crois que tu vas
passer en dessous
c'est juste la
regarde la brée seulement retenu par les
lignes électriques
dans leur coffre quelques précieux litre
d'essence pour pouvoir relancer leur
frigo
ceux qui découvrent en chemin ne les
rassure pas
et
[Musique]
on
n'avait pas assez protéger les portes et
là l'eau est passée
aucun dégât à part un peu d'eau
mais alban est inquiet pour sa
marchandise
elle sombre et froide à peut tenir
jusqu'à trois jours ça fait deux jours
qu'elles sont éteints donc pour
l'instant ça va encore mais j'espérais
avoir décrit site est ici maintenant
c'est toujours par là donc plombé
saint jean
pour la mujer elles sont combien bien
froid
mais fo qui
[Musique]
il a réussi à se procurer un générateur
un bien devenu précieux en ville
il faudra quelques réparations avant
d'ouvrir son commerce à nouveau
[Musique]
vas-y de ces pôles à la table s'envoler
regarde regarde le pied en garde le pied
landreau est là il va partir mais bon
matériel ne sais pas il n'y a pas de
vide de casser encore il n'y a pas de
gros truc quoi c'est plus du désordre on
eu de la chance de ne pas avoir d'objet
pas qu'on volé dans les fenêtres
d'autres dégâts plus importants
en cinq jours florence aura fait 54
morts et 15 milliards d'euros de
dommages
comme après chaque ouragans les
habitants réparent leurs maisons et plus
surprenant il nettoie les routes
ouvertes de poisson a mené par la mer
[Musique]
ici c'est presque devenu une habitude
car en caroline du nord des ouragans
frapperont probablement de nouveau dans
quelques semaines
[Musique]